c'est un moment très important pour le
ministère de l'Intérieur et l'ensemble
des services qui concourent à la
sécurité des Français sécurité avec un S
sécurité au sens où nous l'entendons
évidemment c'est sécurité lutte contre
la délinquance mais également sécurité
civile on a vu à quel point c'était les
Français étaient de plus en plus
inquiets des difficultés qui pouvaient
naître évidemment d'un mauvais modèle de
sécurité civile sécurité cyber on voit
bien à quel point l'actualité nous
pousse à réfléchir à ces sujets très
importants sécurité et intérieure
puisque nous avons aussi des
dispositions messieurs les rapporteurs
vous l'avez constaté sur l'organisation
territoriale de l'État le rôle des
préfets des sous-préfets des agents
préfectures dans l'action de ce
ministère
le hasard mais pas totalement le hasard
vu que le calendrier de ce texte ici
arrive en même temps que la loi de
finances à l'Assemblée nationale puisque
cette loi de programmation prévoit 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires sur
les 5 ans à venir c'est 15 milliards
d'euros la programmation de du texte de
loi que nous vous présentons va de pair
avec la loi programmation des finances
publiques et la loi de finances pour
l'année 2023 qui prévoit bien
l'augmentation de ces 15 milliards
d'euros si j'oserais dire c'est une loi
d'orientation qui est déjà concrète
puisque le Parlement votera en même
temps les crédits nous l'espérons dans
la chambre basse et demain je l'espère
dans la chambre haute
pourquoi une loi de programmation du
ministère de l'intérieur parce que nous
avons considéré que les enjeux qui sont
devant nous qui sont devant le peuple
français mérité comme pour nos amis
militaires une loi de programmation à
une échelle assez longue 50 qui n'a
jamais eu
d'expérience précédente dans la nal du
ministère de l'Intérieur pourquoi parce
que auparavant il y a eu des lobsi des
lois d'orientation et programmation de
la sécurité intérieure il n'y a jamais
eu de l'autre mi pardon pour ce jeu de
mot de programmation de l'ensemble du
ministère de l'Intérieur
et si les lobsi précédentes ont permis
de faire évoluer évoluer pardon la
sécurité intérieure la première
notamment en faisant venir l'image et la
vidéo surveillance lorsque Nicolas
Sarkozy était mise à l'intérieur la
deuxième en revoyant la façon dont on
organisait la sécurité publique dans le
cadre de la RGPP lorsque Nicolas Sarkozy
était président de la République le
ministère de l'Intérieur n'a jamais
connu sur 5 ans des programmations
budgétaires importantes qui lui permet
non pas de répondre aux problèmes ici et
maintenant qu'évidemment concerne
chacune et chacun d'entre nous le
ministère et le ministre intérieur en
premier lieu la délinquance coin de la
rue le point de stup qu'on n'arrive pas
à résorber la personne qu'il faut
accueillir dans le commissariat mais
bien réfléchir à demain c'est à dire aux
crises de demain
et Mesdames et Messieurs dessinateurs je
veux ici défendre le texte en évoquant
les cinq crises auxquelles ce texte
essaye de répondre en y mettant après ce
constat des stratégies et des moyens
budgétaires
la première des crises qui est devant
nous et qui est toujours persistante
c'est la crise terroriste je veux redire
ici devant la Haute Assemblée que la
menace terroriste est extrêmement
prégnante sur le territoire national
dans tout le monde et le monde
occidental en particulier mais en France
bien évidemment je ne reviendrai pas sur
les causes de cette monastéroliste en
France elle a beaucoup de raisons mais
nous devons constater que si nous avons
des jouets plus de 39 attentats depuis
que le Président de la République est
présente de la République les
informations qui nous parviennent les
analyses de ce qui se passe dans
d'autres pays et sans doute la
prospective qui doit naître d'un grand
ministère aussi de ministère d'intérieur
évoque le fait que cette menace théorie
est d'autant plus prégnante qu'elle se
modernise qu'elle se technologie et il
peut être peut-être farfelu devant vous
d'évoquer le fait que les attentats de
demain ne seront pas simplement des
attentats commis avec une arme dans une
salle de spectacle ou avec un couteau en
dehors d'une boulangerie mais par un
drone
chargé d'explosif qui pourrait foncer
sur une foule et créer ainsi comme sur
les théâtres d'opérations extérieures la
terreur comme nous la connaissons
malheureusement sur d'autres armes dites
plus traditionnelles
et c'est le travail du ministère de
l'Intérieur que de prévoir l'acte
terroriste de demain
cet acte terrible demain c'est notamment
la façon dont la loi de programmation
met des moyens extrêmement importants
pour pouvoir répondre à l'intervention
des forces de police et de manière
générale de l'État alors que le cereso
radio par exemple sont extrêmement
éculés monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
accepté que le gouvernement dépose en
séance un amendement qui prévoit en dur
si j'ose dire l'ordonnance qui était
prévu pour le réseau radio du futur
c'est 2 milliards d'euros que nous vous
demandons dans la programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur pour que demain
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
l'ensemble des administrations qui
concourent à la sécurité des Français et
un seul et unique réseau radio capable
d'intervenir en images et en son partout
sur le territoire national et qui est
indépendamment des attaques quelle
qu'elle soit fonctionnent et permettent
à la sécurité civile comme politique
d'intervention au type raid Berry ou
GIGN d'intervenir avec un seul de
communication des sociétés françaises
ont gagné ce marché je peux désormais le
rendre public notamment la société
Airbus qui fait partie de celle qui a
gagné ce grand marché public que nous
avons lancé que nous espérons concrets
avec la loi évidemment voter et il est
évident que la crise terroriste de
demain fait naître évidemment un travail
d'anticipation la lutte antidrone dont
nous devons désormais nous prémunir mais
également de communication c'est le cas
du réseau radio du futur
la deuxième crise que je voudrais
évoquer ici c'est une crise d'ordre
public
chacun a pu constater à la faveur de la
crise des gilets jaunes que les
manifestations de papa étaient terminées
c'est fini du temps où les préfets ou
les mises intérieur se mettaient
d'accord éventuellement avec des grandes
organisations syndicales avec un service
d'ordre organisé et ce métier d'accord
sur les chemins même s'il y avait
plusieurs millions de personnes qui
manifestaient ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui soutenons-le et finalement
avec des policiers aguerris puisque
l'ordre public est un métier qui n'est
pas un métier fait par d'autres
policiers que ceux qui sont formés à
l'ordre public pouvait répondre à ces
manifestations nombreuses sans qu'il y
ait des débordements qui soient au-delà
de l'acceptable chacun désormais a vu
que les manifestations sont spontanées
numériques difficilement chiffrable sans
organisateur aussi peu
peut déclarer avec bien évidemment une
multiplicité de manifestations sur le
territoire national alors qu'évidemment
les villes moyennes ou les villes plus
petites ne connaissaient pas ce qu'on
connu tous les samedis des gilets jaunes
des années précédentes
l'une des difficultés de ces
manifestations venaient du fait que nous
ayons un service de renseignement peu
organisé en tout cas peu organisé pour
comprendre ces manifestations nouvelles
qui touchent d'ailleurs l'ensemble du
monde occidental et pas simplement bien
sûr la France
et du nombre de policiers qu'il manquait
spécialiste dans l'ordre public pour
organiser ces manifestations je suis
bien malheureux objet de constater que
15 escadrons de gendarmes gendarmerie
mobile et de Cérès ont été supprimés ces
20 dernières années et lorsque la crise
des gilets jaunes est venue les nombres
de policiers spécialisés dans l'ordre
public qui demande un entraînement qui
demande un matériel qui demande un
nombre et une stratégie particulière
était peu nombreuses et ont parfois
forcé des policiers dont ce n'était pas
le métier on a parfois vu des policiers
municipaux utilisés par les mairies
parce que il fallait bien répondre aux
difficultés que nous connaissions des
difficultés extrêmement graves pour les
policiers eux-mêmes bien évidemment mais
aussi pour les manifestants et le
travail du ministre de l'intérieur c'est
de permettre aux manifestants même ceux
qui manifestent contre la police
peut-être en sécurité le paradoxe
démocratique veut qu'il soit ainsi
souligné prenons en compte cette
difficulté d'ordre public nouvelle et
ces manifestations de nouvelles formules
nous vous proposons la recréation de 11
escadron de gendarmes immobile ou de CRS
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
du ministère de l'Intérieur donc depuis
25 ans réparti en 7 escadron de
gendarmerie mobile 4 unités de CRS 10 8
mobile on aura l'occasion d'en parler
monsieur le rapporteur évidemment sur
cette nouvelle stratégie d'ordre public
je voudrais aussi souligner que le choix
de recréer cette unités d'escadron de
gendarmerie mobile répond aussi à nos
difficultés ultramarines dont vous savez
que l'essentiel est géré par des
gendarmes mobiles et non pas par des CRS
et qu'il s'agisse des événements
potentiels en Nouvelle-Calédonie des
difficultés que nous connaissons à
Mayotte et en Guyane il faut aussi
savoir regarder les choses telles
qu'elles sont et il est fort à parier
que quel que soit le gouvernement quel
que soit la majorité des assemblées le
gouvernement de la République la
puissance publique aura besoin davantage
d'escadron de gendarmerie et de CRS pour
répondre à la fois manifestations
spontanées numériques et nouvelles et en
même temps aux crises
ultramarines que nous pouvons connaître
il s'agit donc de professionnaliser
l'ordre public encore plus que nous
avons fait jusqu'à présent et de s'en
donner les moyens et la recréation de
ces escadrons à partir de ce constat
méritent sans doute une autre
programmation même si je veux ici
souligner que pendant les deux
prochaines années budgétaires nous
recréerons l'intégralité de ces 11
escadrons et CRS pour que nous soyons
prêts également pour les Jeux Olympiques
qui est notre grand rendez-vous si j'ose
dire et qui va rythmer cette loi de
programmation du ministère de
l'Intérieur merci Madame la Ministre
madame la Présidente pardon
quoi que vous en disiez ici les citoyens
et les citoyens ne se sentent pas
forcément égaux dans leur rapport avec
la police selon l'endroit où vous vivez
ou quel âge vous avez le nombre de
contrôles d'identité par exemple est
très variable je vous invite quand vous
rencontrez les scolaires dans un lycée
ou dans un collège en fonction des
territoires de leur demander qui est
déjà été contrôlé vous verrez c'est
assez variable en fonction de là où vous
allez par exemple pour les jeunes des
quartiers populaires les contrôles ont
lieu plusieurs fois par mois pour
certains sans aucun motif apparent
parfois et quand vous faites contrôler
de manière répétée pour ne pas dire
abusive l'image que vous pouvez avoir de
la police et l'État est nécessairement
dégradé et donc nous vous proposons ici
que les statistiques de contrôle
identité soient rendus publics par
tranche d'âge et par zone géographique
l'idée est d'objectiver les faits pour
arrêter de faire l'autruche et de se
renvoyer à des caricatures peut-être que
lorsque l'on se rendra compte qu'un
jeune vivant à La Courneuve a infiniment
plus de chances de se faire contrôler
qu'un jeune vivant ici par exemple dans
le sixième arrondissement de Paris les
politiques commenceront à changer les
pratiques sur le terrain elles-mêmes
mais peut-être que ça démontre à
l'inverse et donc seule une transparence
sous les indicateurs objectifs pourra
nous éclairer
merci Monsieur dessus monsieur le
rapporteur
les modalités de réalisation des
contrôles d'identité sont précisées par
la taxe 78 2 du code de procédure pénale
qui est très bien écrit et qui cite de
manière limitative les cas dans lesquels
les contrôles peuvent être réalisés il y
a pas lieu de rajouter des statistiques
et des analyses qui vont une fois de
plus encombrer la lourdeur
administrative alors que nous attendons
que nos policiers soient maximum sur le
terrain défavorable
même avis monsieur le ministre monsieur
benaroche pour explication de vote
que tout est parfait qui a un gros
problème sur les contrôles d'identité
dans notre pays alors que tout le monde
le note que tout le monde le sait que
tout le prouve et que tous les
témoignages le montrent ça ne veut pas
dire pour autant qu'il n'y a pas lieu
d'avoir plus de contrôle d'identité à
des endroits en fonction de situation
délictueuses ça veut juste dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a aucun critère qui
nous permet d'évaluer si ces
contre-identité sont fait effectivement
de manière homogène et de manière
concrètement aux circonstancié c'est
tout et on demande ça et vous le savez
très bien c'est une des raisons aussi de
la perte de confiance de Grenoble de
citoyens c'est parce qu'on pense que les
contrôles d'identité sont pas faits
d'une manière on va dire
cohérente entre les différentes couches
sociales raciales etc disons-le donc
disons-le c'est la vérité tout le monde
le sait
donc du moment quand le dit
peut-être mais enfin on utilise les mots
qui sont ceux qui viennent et qui sont
ceux qui sont utilisés par les gens
aussi donc je vous le dis les contrôles
d'identité sont pas fait de la manière
dont ils devraient faire et en tout cas
s'il le sort on aimerait bien
effectivement avoir des éléments
statistiques je suis désolé monsieur le
rapporteur qui nous permet de le juger
qui nous permet qui nous permet d'en
faire une étude une étude sociologique
qui nous permette d'en tirer des
conclusions qui seront valables et qui
seront utiles à tout le monde y compris
au ministre de l'Intérieur et à la
police
si chers collègues monsieur le ministre
vous avez la parole
monsieur le monsieur sénateur
je pense que vos propos ont dépassé
votre pensée
parce que ce que vous dites clairement
c'est que la police de la République une
partie d'entrée des racistes puisque si
on passe si on base des contrôles que
vous dénoncez sur une forme raciale
c'est donc effectivement que l'on
distingue selon une race et donc elle
serait raciste ces propos sont
profondément blessants et insultants
pour les policiers de la République vous
dépend avoir beaucoup pour imaginer
qu'il n'y a par ailleurs qu'une type de
police créative de policiers dans la
police nationale c'est une insulte à
tous ceux qui
issus eux-mêmes de l'immigration
contribue par leur courage à avoir
qu'une couleur de peau celle du drapeau
de le rouge qui les épousent lorsqu'ils
acceptent d'être gardien de la paix ou
d'être gendarmes d'ailleurs monsieur
sénateur vous imaginez bien facile votre
discours en évoquant jamais le fait que
eux-mêmes sont et ça c'est tout à fait
vérifié l'objet d'insulter raciste
quand des policiers
c'est pas drôle du tout en fin d'accuser
les gens de racisme je pense que vous
devriez pas vous amuser de ce point et
me faites pas le discours de des
quartiers populaires j'en viens j'ai
dirigé une commune et cher ami je pense
que vous n'avez aucune leçon dans
bourgeoison de 6e arrondissement et vous
avez je me semble-t-il pas d'expérience
ni humaine ni politique que j'ai pu
avoir dans ma commune où je suis
d'ailleurs toujours élu mais je vais
vous dire quelque chose je vais vous
dire non mais parce que les discours
bien-pensants les discours bien pensants
les discours bien-pensants ça suffit
monsieur le sénateur si je peux me
permettre parce qu'accuser les fonctions
de la République de racisme c'est
profondément grave et par bien sûr que
vous l'avez dit bien sûr que vous l'avez
dit vous avez une liberté parlant cette
hémicycle permettez-moi de défendre les
policiers les gendarmes de la République
et c'est tout à fait conforme à ce que
dit Monsieur Mélenchon de manière
générale il y a bien une filiation
politique manifestement et vous êtes
bien isolé dans cette hémicycle puisque
je crois qu'à sa zone de vos collègues
de votre formation
électorale pour bien pris soin de se
démarquer de cette situation parce que
vous savez monsieur le sénateur et
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe surtout
c'est quand des policiers ou des
gendarmes qui ont des couleurs de peau
différente de ceux qui le contrôle ils
sont traités eux de harki qui pour eux
d'ailleurs est une insulte et qui pour
moi ne l'est pas ils se font traiter de
traîtres alors que ils ne font
qu'impliquer les lois de la République
en essayant de protéger en concitoyens
parce que vous oubliez une chose et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'une grande
partie des Français aiment leur police
nationale parce que il n'y a pas de
désaveu des Français et la police
nationale c'est l'administration la plus
aimée de toutes les administrations
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ce
qui est sûr c'est que votre gauche à
vous et la quitté les forces de l'ordre
à force de ne pas voir que il protégeait
les plus populaires d'entre nous et que
c'est les populations qui sont les plus
pauvres souvent issus d'immigration qui
vivent les difficultés délinquants sans
premier parce que les plus riches
d'entre nous ils ont les moyens d'avoir
leur propre caméra de vidéoprotection
leur propre quartier parfois leur propre
police et c'est parce que vous avez
abandonné les policiers les gendarmes de
la République par ces discours vos kyste
et racialiste que vous faites que vous
faites que si vous faites un procès un
procès qui est inacceptable monsieur le
sénateur il n'acceptable et c'est
ignorer le droit monsieur le sénateur
c'est ignoré le droit à vous qui prenez
l'action de la justice que de savoir que
vous l'a dit monsieur le rapporteur
qu'il n'y a pas un policier de la
République il y a pas un gendarme qui
fait pas un contrôle d'entité sans
l'autorisation d'un procureur de la
République donc en plus de dire des
choses qui sont profondément blessantes
vous dites des choses qui ont profité
dans un fosse
merci la parole est à Monsieur Gontard
monsieur le ministre c'est ce que vous
avez dit et profondément blessant aussi
dans votre manière de l'exprimer et
surtout dans cet outrance vous n'avez
pas d'autres éléments qu'est-ce qu'on
demande dans cette dans cette amendement
d'évaluer d'évaluer d'avoir des
statistiques à disposition pour pouvoir
discuter et justement pour être dans
l'apaisement alors je comprends bien
dans vos propos que l'apaisement c'est
pas quelque chose que qui vous
caractérise c'est bien dommage parce que
je pense qu'on a besoin d'apaisement on
a besoin d'apaisement on a besoin de
rassembler les Français et de les
renouer avec leur avec leur police et le
fait d'avoir des statistiques des
chiffres une évaluation précise ça
permet ça et c'est certainement pas à
travers vos propos qu'on arrivera
justement à apaiser cette situation je
regrette regrette vivement et je ne
comprends pas en tout cas j'ai pas eu un
argument qui ferait que cet amendement
ne soit pas voté juste pour avoir des
éléments réels
merci chers collègues alors je vais
mettre au voile amendement 144 qu'a reçu
deux avis défavorables qui est pour
qui contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté nous
passons aux articles additionnels après
le 7 et nous avons un amendement 33 de
la présidente rossignol
monsieur
le président que j'ai déjà défendu à
plusieurs reprises quand on a modifié
l'ordonnance du protection et que je
déposerai et que je défendrai
inlassablement jusqu'à ce qu'un jour
j'en suis sûr je souhaite suivi par le
Parlement et le gouvernement et c'est
l'expérience des précédentes qui
m'amènent à penser ça puisque les textes
ont évolué régulièrement au cours des
trois dernières années sur ces sujets
j'explique très simplement l'ordonnance
de protection prévoit des conditions
cumulatives il faut l'existence de
violence et un danger or
de nombreuses victimes ou leurs avocats
nous font nous informent du fait que
certains juges sont un JAF ont une
interprétation très restrictive de cette
condition cumulative il peut arriver que
des violences n’est pas encore été
commises ou du moins que la victime ne
puisse pas en apporter la preuve elle ne
peut apporter la preuve que des menaces
d'ailleurs ça renvoie à des amendements
qu'on verra tout à l'heure qui sont les
amendements de notre collègue Bazin sur
l'utilisation des animaux
domestiques dans les conflits de couple
alors je sais quand ils ont été
présentés en commission des lois ça va
un peu surpris et fait sourire et moi ça
m'a pas fait sourire parce que je
comprends exactement ce qu'il veut faire
c'est à dire que je vais tuer ton chat
je vais partir avec le chien ce sont des
menaces et qui parfois amène au passage
à l'acte donc je propose
non
on ne commence pas à discuter sur les
chiens et les chats on va se perdre je
propose que on remplace la condition
cumulative par un le et par le ou
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut soit des
violences soit des menaces et c'est
nécessaire parce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'ordonnances de protection qui ne
peuvent pas être prononcées parce que
les menaces de violence n'ont pas encore
été commises et pour autant
la femme qui vient demander une tendance
de protection est incontestablement dans
une grande situation de danger donc
c'est une c'est un amendement vraiment
utile dans la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales j'espère mes chers
collègues vous a convaincu cette fois-ci
monsieur le reporter
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
alors au risque pour le coup des
désagréables à Madame Rossignol d'une
manière générale il ne nous semble pas
que ce texte sur le cadre adapté pour
réformer l'ordonnance de protection je
comprends que vous défendiez avec
constance cette réforme moi je défendrai
avec content de consens cette ligne sur
vos amendements comme sur les
amendements notamment de Monsieur Bazin
tout à l'heure
donc non mais j'entends mais il faut un
peu de méthodologie dans cette maison
pour qu'on puisse mener des sujets à
bout et les mener dans les bons
véhicules législatifs il nous semble pas
de plus
souhaitable de préserver une certaine
stabilité des rives de droit de
protection a été réformée en 2020 ce qui
nous semble être tout à fait récent nous
avons par conséquent émis un avis
défavorable pour l'ensemble des
amendements relatifs à l'ordonnance de
protection je le redirai autant de fois
que nécessaire dans la discussion des
amendements qui qui intervient
maintenant
certes dans la discussion sur les
violences centrales familiales et les
conformes à l'article nous présentons
mais c'est le juge civil que vous
appelez c'est-à-dire que déjà on a du
mal à aller vers le juge pénal quand on
fait quand on est intègre ministère de
l'Intérieur et vous avec moi que là
c'est le juge civil que l'on convoque
donc on va quand même assez loin dans
les compétences que peut avoir le
ministre de l'Intérieur pour défendre un
texte un texte au banc après moi je
trouve que si votre idée je peux la
comprendre et je comprends votre
démarche j'y suis a priori favorable une
question d'urgence aussi parce que s'il
y a menace c'est le juge pénal qui doit
intervenir et l'ordonnance de protection
est une autre forme de protection et ne
traite pas les menaces qui pourraient
être sanctionnées par le pain juge pénal
donc indépendamment du fond qui mérite
sans doute des auditions et des
discussions que vous avez de propre
expérience il est grande je veux bien me
ranger à votre argument je vois pas
comment on pourrait conduire dans un
texte mistrateur des changements de
fonctionnement du Code civil donc voilà
je pense que par souci de respect des
compétences de chacune et de chacun
renvoyant ainsi le travail que vous avez
proposé monsieur le rapporteur un avis
défavorable
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur le ministre je vais
céder la place à ma collègue Dominique
Verrien qui était prête à se lever
également concernant la volonté de par
amendement de notre collègue Laurence
Rossignol de modifier l'ordonnance de
protection je pense que on doit
véritablement se poser
différentes questions
la lutte contre les violences
intrafamiliales à évolué on a voté tout
un tas de textes il y a eu la libération
de la parole et on connaît de mieux sans
mieux les processus qui amènent et c'est
vrai que ce et où en réalité lorsqu'on
dit danger et ou existence de violence
en réalité on a du mal à une menace est
un et également une une violence en
réalité donc je comprends la la volonté
de notre collègue Laurence Rossignol
parce que il y a quelque part ici une
interprétation de de la du danger parce
que on le montre tous les jours dans ce
des violences intrafamiliales les le
danger la violence c'est aussi l'emprise
les menaces qui sont exercées sur les
victimes donc bien entendu voilà je
comprends vraiment cette volonté de
modifier l'ordonnance de protection et
j'entends aussi le rapporteur je vais
attendre les différentes explications
puisque madame Rossignol a souhaité
répondre également aux rapporteurs et
aux ministres madame
merci Monsieur président en fait pour
cet amendement comme pour le précédent
et comme pour les suivants il est vrai
que on n'est pas logiquement dans la
loopmie pour parler de ces sujets
chers collègues vous savez que nous
sommes en train de faire nous démarrons
une mission
parlementaire enfin oui nous sommes
parlementaires en mission pour
travailler sur les violences
intrafamilales et il est évident que
l'ensemble de ces points doit être vu je
vais en profiter pour dire quand même un
petit mot sur l'amendement précédent
mais effectivement
Laurence sera Rossignol l'ayant retiré
j'ai pas pu faire ce commentaire il est
clair que il y a eu des problèmes avec
des femmes qui n'ont pas été prévenus de
la sortie de leur conjoint violent de
prison je sais pour le coup pour
regarder ça que la Chancellerie a fait
des retours d'expérience et en train de
diffuser des informations suffisamment
ferme pour que cela ne puisse pas de
nouveau arriver donc il sera temps
éventuellement s'il est nécessaire de le
faire rentrer dans la loi mais parfois
énormément de bonnes pratiques ne sont
pas obligatoirement ne doivent pas
obligatoirement passer par le législatif
mais il est clair que c'est une chose
qui a été très bien identifiée et que
nous veillerons à ce que ce soit la
règle vraiment immuable dorénavant merci
Madame Sempé
la demande madame madame rossignol
je sais bien que on a déjà réformé
l'ordonnance de protection et puis je
vous prends le pari qu'on va encore la
réformer parce que sur ces sujets notre
connaissance est presque empirique c'est
à dire que c'est au fur et à mesure
qu'on réformes au fur et à mesure qu'on
connaît la pratique de la loi la queue
on découvre qu'il y a des lacunes et des
dysfonctionnements moi mon but il est
simple et je veux dire aux collègues
dans cette émission moi il y a des
sujets sur lesquels je fais confiance
aux collègues parce que je sais que ce
sont des spécialistes certes vous n'avez
pas auditionné tous les avocats sur le
sujet moi je fais que ça depuis 10 ans
si je dis qu'il y a un problème est
particulièrement sur celui-ci faites-moi
conscient confiance faites-moi confiance
c'est parce que des avocats me le disent
parce que les juges aux affaires
familiales alors monsieur le ministre
c'est vrai que la danse de protection
est une affaire de droits civiles mais
vous connaissez bien la nature un peu
hybride de l'ordonnance de protection
qui est une mesure qui est une mesure
qui prend des décès qui qui amènent des
décisions d'éloignement de d'éloignement
d'interdiction d'approcher qui sont
presque de nature un peu pénale quand
même donc et d'ailleurs on verra que
dans les mois à venir on parlera la
capacité pour les procureurs de
prononcer des ordonnances de protection
donc bien sûr ces justes mais là moi on
est dans l'urgence c'est-à-dire que
pendant qu'on parle pendant qu'on parle
pendant qu'on se dit que c'est pas le
bon texte pendant ce temps-là il y a des
juges aux affaires familiales qui
connaissent pas bien qui sont pas encore
adaptés parce que il y a quelques il y a
deux ans il y avait on est à 10 fois
plus d'ambiance de protection les
chiffres m'échappent à cet instant donc
les juges découvrent et appréhendent de
protection je vous assure je vous
garantis qu'il y a un problème dans
cette condition cumulative la menace
précède le danger
et si on ne peut pas prendre si leur
nanance de protection est ensuite
annulée par en par le recours en appel
parce qu'elle n'est pas conforme à la
loi parce que parce que le juge d'appel
va appliquer la loi ces femmes ne sont
pas protégées et après on vient dire oh
là là il y a encore eu un
dysfonctionnement elle avait pas moyen
de protection elle n'a pas eu puis après
il est passé à l'acte et toutes les
menaces on les connaissait au moment où
l'ambiance de protection a été refusé
parce que la loi de prévoit pas qu'elle
puisse être accordée donc vraiment
faites-moi confiance monsieur
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
signatrice continuole je ne mets
absolument pas en doute vos compétences
ni la permanence de votre de vos
conviction là-dessus d'ailleurs si j'en
moi-même à la télévision au droit des
femmes depuis maintenant quelques
quelques années auprès de la prison de
Lyon et d'autres personnes je sais
l'importance que vous attachez à ces
sujets-là et je crois faire partie de
ceux qui sont particulièrement attentive
à cela si le Sénat et la commission des
lois nomme des rapporteurs sur un texte
et qu'on définit un périmètre et qu'on
essaye au maximum de maintenir le débat
si le gouvernement a nommé madame la
députée Chandler et madame la sénatrice
je vais rien ici présente ce matin sur
comme parlementaire en mission sur ces
questions là je vous donne je vous donne
acte que effectivement il y aura des
propositions qui seront faites par la
mission des deux parlementaires que je
viens que je viens de nommer néanmoins
encore une fois on nous sommes dans un
texte d'orientation de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur je pense que si
le débat est important qu'il est
intéressant les deux transporteur nous
n'avons pas mené les auditions
nécessaires je rappelle et je prends
témoin Jérôme du Rhin que les auditions
sont ouvertes au membre de la commission
des lois que de nombreux collègues ont
participé qu'on est obligé de maintenir
une certaine méthode dans ce texte si
nous vous voulons pour cet amendement là
mais aussi pour d'autres qui vont venir
tout à l'heure dans la discussion on est
on est je suis contraint de rendre et de
maintenir un avis défavorable
je mets donc aux voix l'amendement 34
proposé par notre collègue 33 autant
pour moi qui est pour
donc
toujours après l'article 7 en amendement
en article additionnel l'amendement 34
de la présidente
je nous souhaite que il y ait pas de
d'accident entre le moment où on vote et
puis le moment où on revotera un jour
quelque chose qui me permettra que la
loi soit mieux adaptée à la protection
des femmes et des enfants victimes de
violence mais je vous assure que les
dossiers qui vont me remonter maintenant
je vais tous vous les partager je vais
les vous les envoyer pour comme ça vous
pourrez aussi constater les conséquences
de nos votes alors le deuxième
l'amendement 34 j'ai tous les présenter
en même temps parce qu'il concernant de
protection c'est la dissimulation de
domicile du domicile de la victime
puisque vous savez que malgré une
ambiance de protection les hommes
violents peuvent retrouver le domicile
de la victime et donc perpétuer leur
violence mais bon j'imagine que ça c'est
le deuxième Sénat d'allongement de délai
le troisième ça concerne la question de
la prise en charge des femmes non
mariées sans enfant dans leur danse de
protection et le dernier qui
n'est pas la même chose je m'arrêterai
donc au 32 voilà trois amendements sont
annonces de protection je ne me fais
aucune illusion et on prend poursuivra
cette discussion
merci monsieur le président
je n'ai pas tellement l'habitude de
prendre la parole mais même Rossignol
même la ministre tout de même
le rapporteur a expliqué pourquoi nous
avons donné la Commission à donner à la
vie défavorable à vos amendements ce
n'est pas une question de fond nous
avons tous conscience de ce que vous
avez dit et de l'utilité de ce que vous
avez dit mais c'est une question de
circonstance de texte de référence et
d'analyse supplémentaire nécessaire
voilà la réalité des choses c'est notre
travail à la commission des lois mais
madame je ne peux pas accepter les
propos que vous avez tenus à quelques
secondes qui consiste à nous faire du
chantage
qui consiste à faire du chantage à vos
collègues parlementaires et ça je vous
demande de retirer ces propos s'il vous
plaît
madame la Présidente
aucun de mes propos je n'ai fait aucun
chantage aucun chantage je vous ai
simplement dit que comme je suis
destinataire de nombreux dossiers qui
justement
pointe les insuffisances de l'ordonnance
de protection comme vous avez vous et
leur importeur et je vous ai bien
entendu évoqué le fait que vous n'aviez
pas eu le temps vous n'avez pas pris
c'était pas dans le concept du texte
d'auditionner des avocats de vous
informer sur le dossier je vous ai
simplement dit que pour votre
information je vous présenterai
destinataire des dossiers que je reçois
c'est pas un chantage ni même une menace
vote
sur les amendements pardon en effet je
n'ai pas encore recueilli la vie de la
commission donc il faut que je le fasse
sur les trois amendements qui a présenté
madame Rossignol alors ils sont vendu on
va le faire comme ça alors la vie
défavorable sur les trois
président
madame la ministre je veux pas alourdir
le débat sur le sujet mais on reprendra
les propos que vous avez tenus devant
l'ensemble des collègues et il constitue
un chantage si je dois vous envoyer la
définition de ce qui est un chantage je
le ferai sans délai
monsieur le ministre votre avis sur les
amendements
que je comprends les souhaits de
modifier l'ordonnance et sans doute elle
a mille fois raison pour répondre à
l'empirisme que nous constatons mais lui
redire mais elle le sait très bien je
pense qu'elle en est soucieuse que c'est
quand même un sujet du ministère de la
Justice et des dispositions qui relèvent
du code soit civil soit pénal mais il
est vrai que le texte de l'intérieur que
nous présentons mais un certain nombre
de choses qui améliore la vie des
policiers et des gendarmes même s'ils
sont agissent sous l'autorité des
magistrats et qui ne touchent pas
profondément les codes qui concerne les
injustices et je relierai monsieur mise
à justice Vous interpellations et vos
amendements
donc en explication de votre maintenant
monsieur benaroche
c'est notre assemblée était une
assemblée raisonnable et sage
personnellement je dois le dire monsieur
le Président buffet je n'ai pas ressenti
les paroles de Laurence Rossignol comme
étant un chantage
écoutez on peut avoir une conception
différente j'ai le droit de dire que je
n'ai pas ressenti les paroles de
Laurence Rossignol comme étant un
chantage ça ne veut pas dire vous les
avez pas ressenti d'une autre façon je
ne vois pas pourquoi vous offusquez de
cette remarque donc je n'ai pas ressenti
les paroles de Laurence Rossignol comme
un chantage ainsi qu'à certains nombre
de mes collègues je pense qu'elle a
fondamentalement raison sur le fond je
pense que les rapporteurs l'ordi avec le
ministre l'a dit et je pense qu'elle dit
juste qu'entre le moment où nous disons
tous il faut le faire et le moment où
nous allons le faire nous ne savons pas
quand un certain nombre d'événements
peuvent se produire et que nous tous
pouvant être comptable quelque part de
la responsabilité de ces événements en
tout cas il est normal que nous en
soyons informés et je pense que c'est
logique que lorsque dit ça donc
personnellement je voterai ces
amendements et je ne lui demande pas
d'excuse
madame billon a demandé la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur monsieur les rapporteurs
monsieur le ministre moi je regrette
l'attention soudaine sur un sujet en
réalité qui nous préoccupe tous et on
sait on connaît l'engagement des uns et
des autres sur ce sujet leur rapporteur
notamment qui est oui membre de la
délégation au droit des femmes comme
Laurence Rossignol dans son parcours
politique on est tous investis alors ce
que je voudrais dire c'est ce sujet il
est majeur oui il est majeur j'entends
que les rapporteurs n'ont pas eu la
capacité à travailler évidemment sur ce
sur ces thématiques mais ce que je
voudrais dire à monsieur le ministre
c'est que ce sujet il est majeur il est
posé sur la table et qu'en réalité
toutes les lois qu'on a votées à ce jour
n'arrivent pas à inverser les
statistiques des violences
intrafamiliales donc il y a forcément
des progrès à faire des pistes de
progrès moi je retiendrai de
l'intervention de ma collègue Laurence
Rossignol surtout les les les
propositions qu'elle fait je pense que
ces propositions sont elles sont
peut-être pas utiles dans ce texte mais
sur les rapporteurs mais il va falloir
qu'on s'en saisisse et lorsque notre
collègue Dominique Verrien fait état de
la mission oui bien entendu il y a une
mission on va laisser la mission
travailler même si pour ma part je suis
totalement convaincu par une juridiction
spécialisée pour lutter contre les
violences intrafamilales mais laissons
la mission travailler et puis on verra
les conclusions donc je voulais faire
cette intervention en toute sérénité
pour tous les bancs du Sénat je vous
remercie madame merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
bah oui quelquefois on se sent vraiment
inutile quelquefois on veut des choses
et puis on se sent presque coupable en
disant mais il y a encore des victimes
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait qu'est-ce qu'on a
voté pourquoi on n'a pas rédigé ça mieux
alors ce que j'ai compris à la
commission des lois c'est qu'on fait du
droit et rien que du droit et que
vraiment de temps en temps il faut
mettre notre émotion dans la poche parce
que ce qu'on voudrait faire ce qu'on
peut peut-être faire quelques fois dans
le secret professionnel de nos cabinets
médicaux et bien on ne veut pas
forcément l'écrire dans la loi donc je
partage bien évidemment le fond de la
protection des enfants le fond de la
production des femmes comme vous l'avez
dit mes chers collègues soit la
déviation de droit des femmes ou dans
les travaux que on mène depuis longtemps
à la commission des lois et je dois dire
avec toutes les côtes du président
buffet et là avec l'écoute des
rapporteurs en ce qui concerne ce texte
donc évidemment qu'on voudrait toujours
faire mieux mais il y a quelque chose
qu'on ne changera pas c'est des
mentalités parce que les lois elles sont
souvent écrites mais elles sont souvent
peut-être pas très bien appliquées mais
bien connu alors on est malheureux c'est
vrai on est triste de tout ça mais je
crois qu'il faut garder notre méthode il
faut garder un fil directeur solide de
se dire que ce qu'on écrit c'est dans la
loi qui convient dans le véhicule
législatif qui convient pour justement
ne pas prêter le flanc à des critiquer
qui seraient facile et se dire qu'on
devrait ensemble travailler à la
protection des enfants et du mieux
possible dans un texte qui viendra à ce
sujet
merci monsieur le Président j'ai
beaucoup de respect et je salue je sais
le travail de Laurence Rossignol et je
sais la fougue qu'elle met également
quand elle défend un sujet mais je crois
en l'occurrence que tout à l'heure elle
s'est peut-être
ne s'en est peut-être pas rendu compte
mais certains ont pu se sentir
effectivement visé par ce qu'elle a dit
même si sur le fond je crois que nous
partageons tous tous cette lutte contre
les violences intrafamiliales en
revanche ce qu'a dit le rapporteur et ce
qu'a dit monsieur le Président buffet
ont été de nature parfaitement à
satisfaire et à ramener un peu de
sérénité dans le débat j'amène notre
collègue benaroche aussi
là encore à respecter toutes les voies
sur cette hémicycle chacun s'exprime à
sa façon et quand on y met la foule bien
évidemment on peut déborder mais
concevait que certains ont pu être voilà
atteint par ses paroles et c'est tout ce
que je voulais dire très sereinement
tout tout le monde est au fond
parfaitement d'accord sur l'objectif les
moyens qui ont été qui sont mises en
place voilà l'explication du rapporteur
et du président ont été très clairs
monsieur Bourgy
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
partager avec vous le sentiment de gènes
que je ressens depuis le début de la
matinée un sentiment de gêne parce que
les débats que nous avons aujourd'hui à
l'occasion des amendements que nous
avons examinés depuis 10h30 c'est des
bas nous les avons eu lors de l'examen
du projet de loi durant visant à
renforcer la confiance dans
l'institution judiciaire lorsque nous
avons déposé ces amendements que nous
avons eu ces débats sur l'accueil des
victimes du dépôt de plainte sur
l'accompagnement des victimes par un
avocat au parlement d'une association
agréée l'information des victimes tout
au long de la procédure les actes commis
après le jugement le garde des sceaux
nous a indiqué adressez-vous au ministre
de l'Intérieur
aujourd'hui nous avons le ministre de
l'Intérieur au banc du gouvernement et
lorsque nous lui posons certaines
questions ils nous disent c'est en
dehors de mon périmètre adressez-vous au
garde des sceaux je vais donc revenir à
un des vœux qui a été émis par un
orateur du groupe les républicains dans
la discussion générale vivement un
projet de loi qui nous permet
d'interroger concomitamment au banc des
ministres au bord du gouvernement le
garde des sceaux et le ministre de
l'Intérieur nous avons besoin de les
avoir l'un à côté de l'autre pour que
l'un et l'autre puisse nous répondre et
qu'on arrête cette stratégie de la
défense qui consiste à renvoyer à plus
tard et à l'autre les questions que nous
posons
il nous échappe pas que
lorsqu'un texte a été travaillé par la
Commission et qu'il arrive en séance il
n'y a pas lieu à faire des débats
nouveaux voir improviser
et donc ce sujet ne se poserait pas que
le gouvernement est un et qu'il a
toujours une position sur chaque texte
sur chaque élément de texte mais le fait
qu'on travaille en faisant une
découverte de textes en commission alors
qu'on est temps d'assemblée plénière
évidemment ne facilite pas le
déroulement du débat monsieur le
ministre
mais jusqu'à présent je crois qu'on
travaillait dans des conditions de
respect des uns et des autres et sans
attaque personnels ou politiques à
dominium non non madame saint Tristan je
crois que chacun pouvait le constater et
ce que vous dites est à la fois
me semble-t-il déplacé il faut
vous allez oublier monsieur Bourget ou
peut-être des pieds pouvoir dans sa
discussion parlementaire que j'étais là
comme Monsieur le garder soit présenté
son texte en renforcement dans
l'autorité judiciaire et j'ai répondu
avec Monsieur le gardeesseau à vos
interrogations et j'ai même me souviens
très bien d'avoir moi-même accepté et
modifier par sous un moment dans votre
assemblée la disposition qu'on évoquait
tout à l'heure avec le sénateur Favreau
de la présence de l'avocat et de la
personne majeure dans les services de
police donc je pense que les attaques
politiciennes que vous avez de faire le
mérita du débat je crois aujourd'hui
voilà donc c'est un point très très
important si effectivement il m'est
arrivé depuis avant-hier de poser des
arguments interministériels à des
questions qui étaient posées qui
dépassaient le stade du ministre de
l'Intérieur simplement en effet nous
avions pas les amendements 24 heures ou
48 heures avant mais passer par la
commission moi j’échange beaucoup avec
vos rapporteur il présente la commission
des lois je vous rappelle que j'ai
invité l'intégralité de la commission
des lois à venir me rencontrer
ministère de l'Intérieur voilà 15 jours
nous n'avons pas interpellé sur ces
questions tout le monde est invité quel
que soit les groupes politiques on
aurait pu travailler en amont un certain
nombre de choses je me doutais que
Monsieur Durand par exemple et vous
créez des rôdios puisqu'il m'a
interpeller à ce moment-là sur la
question des rodéo donc je pense que
voilà le businessateur à tout le monde
je suis pas sûr qu'il faille trouver des
cours il y en a pas peut-être qu'on
pourrait collectivement monsieur Center
y compris votre groupe politique se dire
qu'on pourrait améliorer la façon dont
on agit pour faire adopter telle ou tel
texte je veux bien mettre ma part à
l'édifice mais c'est pas d'un côté les
méchants de l'autre côté les gentils et
je crois que les questions que vous
évoquez évidemment que lundi madame
Rossignol demande un temps rapide
puisque pendant le soleil il se passe
des choses et elle a bien raison et même
le temps de la loi est un temps long
donc je veux bien comprendre cet
argument mais ne fait pas ici petit
policier vous savez très bien je sais en
faire peut-être pas avec moins de
talents mais je sens faire et je pense
que c'était pas l'idée avec laquelle je
suis venu à ce débat parlementaire chez
elle constate depuis trois jours
toujours pour explication de vote oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais mes chers collègues trois
remarques très respectueuses et
tranquilles la première chose c'est que
la procédure accélérée la procédure
accélérée n'est pas le fait des auteurs
des amendements
on est d'accord ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est que la
question du principe de l'amendement en
séance
personne ne va le remettre en cause à
moins à moins à moins que nous prenions
ici la décision de traiter uniquement
des amendements et là je dégage de ces
responsabilités de ministre c'est les
responsabilités du Sénat de ne parler
d'amendement ayant été traités en
commission moi je pense qu'il faut se
trouver cette souplesse entre à la fois
la qualité d'expertise des commissions
et à la fois le droit d'initiative
parlementaire et donc je finis là-dessus
de manière très tranquille il y a trois
amendements qui posent des questions
certes importantes fin de l'ordonnance
de protection quand elle bénéficie quand
il y a des simulation de l'adresse après
on l'augmentation la durée maximum de
l'ordonnance de protection en la portant
de 6 mois à un an et un troisième
amendement sur les conditions d'accès la
prolongation de l'ordonnance de
protection pour une femme non mariée ou
sans enfant c'est les questions lourdes
moi je me dis très sin je vous le dis il
faut qu'on tranche ces questions par un
vote voilà moi pour ma part je
soutiendrai ces trois notre groupe
soutiendra ces trois amendements et ils
seront discutés voilà ça s'appelle aussi
laisser une souplesse quand même à
l'initiative parlementaire après
peut-être qu'ils ne seront pas adoptés
mais là c'est un choix de nature
politique il y a rien de grave de ce
point de vue là merci
Madame Benbassa
merci président
écoutez malgré tout le respect que je
dois à Monsieur buffet pour son travail
et pour sa direction de notre commission
dans la nous traitons dans la sérénité
et des sujets graves
ce que défend madame Rossignol ce sont
enfin ça nous revient nous faisons ça
tous les jours donc il n'y a pas à
s'offusquer
de ceux que qu'elle a dit je ne crois
pas qu'elle a voulu faire un chantage
loin de là je suppose son idée mais en
même temps on dirait qu'on est des
enfants de cœur que nous sommes là pour
faire que du droit et pas de politique
ça m'étonne un peu en Espagne nous
faisons de la politique aussi ce qu'a
fait madame Rossignol c'est
défendre certains droits et en faisant
de la politique elle défend des causes
je les respecte on nous défendons
beaucoup de choses dans la commission je
défends aussi ce que nous faisons mais
arrêtons cette sensible rique quand même
et passons quand même au coeur de notre
sujet qui est de continuer et de
terminer ce texte dans la bonne humeur
et avec un des discussions
intellectuelles qui quand même sont à
disons au service de nos concitoyens et
ils aiment bien on nous entendre aussi
nous opposer et il n'y a rien de grave à
cela merci nous continuons les
explications de vote c'est tout
président carucci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre moi je ne suis pas membre de la
commission des lois et je ne me sens pas
d'éléments particuliers à la matière
mais comme Monsieur Bourget fait
allusion à mon propos dans la discussion
générale j'avais proposé follement des
étages généraux de la police et de la
justice en même temps je n'avais jamais
demandé ou garde des Sceaux au ministre
de l'Intérieur de venir ensemble ce
qu'ils peuvent parfaitement faire en
revanche moi je suis et là je le dis à
Madame Rossignol un peu gênée de de
l'espèce de non pas de détournement mais
de l'inversion du débat un ministre
représente l'entièreté du gouvernement
c'est la règle
mais un ministre peut difficilement
prendre des décisions accepter des votes
ou donner une opinion sur des
amendements ne correspondant pas à son
secteur du temps glorieux ou
j'exerçais les fonctions de charger des
relations avec le Parlement le président
de la République me disait chaque fois
de bien dire à chaque ministre vous
restez dans votre secteur vous
n'empiétez pas sur les autres parce que
vous pouvez commettre des erreurs et
vous pouvez donner des réponses que
finalement techniquement l'autre
ministre compétent
trouverait un peu aberrant donc moi je
pense que si sur le fond bien des
amendements de Madame Rossignol moi ne
me dérange absolument pas et si c'était
sur un texte justice je les voterai sans
difficulté parce que ça ne me dérange
vraiment pas mais respectons un petit
peu le fait que on peut pas non plus
faire une loi qui soit tellement bavarde
qu'on finit par intégrer des éléments
qui correspondent pas au secteur
correspond dans le titre même de la loi
ce qu'il a fragilise devant le Conseil
constitutionnel je me permets également
de le rappeler et ça n'aurait pas de
sens donc je pense que s'il y a des
engagements de travail sur les
amendements sur le prochain texte que
doit présenter le garde des sceaux on
devrait pouvoir s'en tenir là
madame Rossignol vous demander la parole
et je remercie monsieur le ministre
audiacité parce qu'en fait c'est une
décision qui est assez interne au Sénat
en fait et qui n'est pas en cause le
gouvernement je comprends bien voilà ça
m'est pas en cause le gouvernement je
comprends la difficulté qu'il y a pour
un ministre de se prononcer sur des
amendements qui sont du ressort de son
voisin surtout quand c'est intérieur
justice et par ailleurs je sais aussi
que comme les amendements ont été
transmis il y a déjà plusieurs heures au
ministère de l'Intérieur vos services
ont sollicité la vie de la Chancellerie
donc vous êtes vous avez un avis de la
Chancellerie mais juste je voulais dire
une chose à nos collègues parce que il
est possible d'abord tout le monde fait
du droit ici il y en a pas qui font des
émotions et puis d'autres qui font du
droit tout le monde fait du droit et mes
amendements sont pas bavards ils sont
extrêmement extrêmement rigoureux et sec
dans certains points de vue et il vise à
régler un problème de droit et je ne
suis pas membre de la commission des
lois de la respecter pour mission des
lois pour autant j'évocation en tant que
parlementaire à déposer des amendes sur
tous les textes que je veux et pour
passer un certain nombre d'heures là où
est le président Richard à l'instant je
peux vous assurer que je ne suis pas la
seule à parfois est un peu sur la
tangente de l'objet du texte et avoir
échappé à l'article 45 juste vous dire
une chose j'ai peut-être été certains
disent chantages je ne le crois pas je
ne vois pas en plus arrêter de chantage
menaçante non plus mais juste il y a pas
que le gouvernement qui est responsable
quand il y a un drame on va chercher
quels sont les responsabilités des
services de police de la justice il y a
des inspections les ministres sont mises
en cause sur la manière dont fonctionne
leur service je voulais simplement vous
dire que nous aussi nous sommes
responsables de nos votes même si notre
responsabilité n'est pas souvent mise en
cause mais dans ce que nous votons pour
ou contre nous prenons une part à
l'application des lois le bon
fonctionnement de la justice et de notre
pays et que nous avons une
responsabilité en refusant ses
amendements
merci monsieur le Président nous sommes
tous responsables de nos
votes et nous nos propositions et pour
notre part nous sommes responsables des
avis qui ont été proposés et voter à
deux reprises par la commission des lois
et nous n'avons pas pris personne entre
être ce que je voudrais dire ce matin
c'est qu'imaginer que nous décidions de
réformer l'ordonnance de protection de
toucher au code civil sans avoir jamais
pris la tâche ni du garde des sceaux
pour ce qui nous concerne nous ni
entendu les juges affaires familial ni
mener les auditions nécessaires y
compris dans cette maison avec la
délégation droit des femmes y compris
avec les différents parlementaires qui
s'impliquent sur ces sujets là mais nous
ouvririons le champ à
un précédent qui pourrait nous être
reprochés dans plein d'autres domaines
donc la ligne qui a été définie par les
rapporteurs proposés à la commission des
lois qui en a débattu à deux reprises et
toujours la même il n'y a pas de raison
qu'elle change ce matin des travaux
parlementaires sont en cours le
gouvernement a confié à deux
parlementaires une mission sur le sujet
ne préomptons pas à ces sujets là qui
viendront nécessairement devant le
devant le Parlement et devant nous et en
responsabilité moi je maintiens cette
ligne il me semble que le Sénat est
suffisamment éclairé et que je peux
mettre voix le premier des amendements
présentés par la présidente rossignol
qui est le 34 c'est bien ça
qui est pour
qui est contre
majorité
est-ce que je peux imaginer que ce
serait le même vote sur les amendements
31 et 32
ne sont pas adoptés nous passons donc à
l'article 7 bis sur lequel la taille de
Lattre est inscrite
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues partout sur
notre territoire nous assistons à une
forte reprise des sens des incivilités
surtout des agressions envers les élus
locaux d'après les chiffres du ministère
de l'intérieur de votre ministère publié
en janvier dernier les violences
physiques contre les aides ont augmenté
de 47 % sur les 11 premiers mois de 2021
par rapport à la même période l'année
précédente derrière ces statistiques se
sont exactement 1186 élus qui ont été
pris pour cible et 419 outrages qui ont
été recensés mais seulement une poignée
d'agressions verbale et physique en
faire les élus de la République donne
lieu à une suite judiciaire et dans les
rares situations où une procédure
judiciaire était enclenchée on
enregistre en réalité un très faible
nombre de condamnations même en cas
d'agression physique dans la plupart des
cas les plaintes sont soit classées sans
suite ou ne font l'objet d'aucune suite
pénale c'est pourquoi j'avais déposé un
amendement tiré de ma proposition de loi
qui entendait permettre aux différentes
associations nationales de se constituer
partie civile pour accompagner au pénal
tout élu qui aurait donné préalablement
son accord association qui pourrait
également intervenir en cas de
dégradation d'un bien ou lorsque la
victime est l'un des proches d'un élu au
fin d'acter en justice quasi
systématiquement et minimiser les
classements suisses pour information
nous étudierons cette PPL cette
proposition de loi le 16 novembre
prochain dans cette cycle il est
toutefois dommage que nous n'ayons pu
saisir cette occasion pour l'inscrire
dès aujourd'hui dans cette loi car en
l'espèce le temps n'arrange rien merci
donc sur cette sur cet article qui je le
signale donnera lieu un scrutin public
demandé par un groupe
nous sommes saisis de quatre amendements
discussions communes trois qui sont les
amendements de suppression et un
amendement de la commission de
modification donc le premier dans
l'ordre c'est Monsieur benaroche
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement c'est bien un amendement
de suppression de trois alinéa de 4
alinéa pardon de cet article
qui sont en fait les alinéaires qui
suppriment des dispositions introduites
en commission par notre apporteur
monsieur dobresse on a bien compris que
l'article 7 bis vise à réprimer plus
sévèrement le refus d'obtempérer en
alourdissant la peine encourue et en
diminuant les crédits de réduction de
peine auxquels peuvent prétendre pour
bonne conduite des personnes condamnées
à une peine privative de liberté après
avoir commis cette infraction
la peine encourue serait donc porter à 3
heures d'emprisonnement et à 30000 euros
d'amende et les crédits de réduction de
peine qui peuvent accorder sur et
diminuer d'un tiers
les dispositions prévoient également j'y
reviendrai de réprimer spécifiquement
les rodéo urbains
en ce qui concerne la mesure concernant
diminuer les crédits de réduction de
peine auxquelles les personnes qui a
donné peuvent prétendre ils nous sommes
qu'elles ne peut s'avérer que quand
notre productif dans les faits les
professionnels de la justice les
professionnels de l'administration
pénitentiaire
utilise ses crédits vous le savez comme
un outil encourageant l'adoption d'un
comportement respectueux des règles
internes alors c'est vrai qu'on en parle
plutôt dans les textes portés par le
ministère de la Justice je peux pas
revenir sur la discussion précédente
mais les crédits de peine concerne le
prisonnier il concerne pas le délinquant
c'est un des outils de gestion de la
réinsertion qui est aussi le rôle de la
prison les spips le mettent bien en
avant également mettre fin à ce système
d'octroi ou de retrait des crédits pour
telle ou tel individu revient en fait à
supprimer un moyen de sanctionner de
régulation des comportements de la
population carterrale en ce qui concerne
la loi renforçant la lutte contre les
rodéo motorisés je rappellerai qu'il y
en a une qui a été de 5 août 2018 avec
des dispositions qui s'appliquent déjà
qui ont des résultats et qui sont
satisfaisantes pour sanctionner les
auteurs de ce délits renforcer donc ces
peines ne n'aura pas d'effets sur le
taux d'interpellation de ces individus
je pense que c'est plutôt une mesure
d'affichage si Monsieur Durin pour
présenter le 28
bon
nous abordons avec ces
cet articles un sujet très politique
d'ailleurs il y a un scrutin public qui
a été demandé et d'ailleurs nous
n'étions pas favorables à l'amendement
99 qui avait été déposé par Marc
Philippe de Bresse qui joignait dans un
même élan le sujet de la condamnation
des personnes l'aggravation des peines
du quantum de Pen pour les agresseurs
d'élus en alignant le dispositif sur
d'autres dépositaires de l'autorité
publique et qui mettaient dans le même
amendement le sujet des rodéo urbains et
le sujet des refus d'obtempérer nous
sommes très favorables à ce qui concerne
les élus il y a une forme de logique
imparable à ce qu'il soit protégé au
même titre que d'autres dépositaires de
l'autorité publique en revanche nous
estimons sur les refus d'obtempérer et
sur les
urbains ce sera notre amendement suivant
que
le simple durcissement des peines ne
conduit pas à l'efficacité je partage
l'argumentaire de notre collègue
benaroche qui vient de développer à
l'instant
nous prononçons pour la suppression des
Néa qui concernent le refus d'obtempérer
ainsi que sur les urbains ce sera le
l'amendement suivant
un policier de la BAC a été traîné au
sol hier à Lyon
donc je le dis tout de suite c'est pas
parce qu'on supprime ces dispositions
qu'on considère qu'il faut laisser les
policiers gendarmes exposés à tous les
individus qui sont dans une position de
refus d'obtempérer et qui mettent leur
vie en danger en revanche notre position
elle est constante elle tient au rapport
police population il y a autour du sujet
des refus d'obtempérer une vraie
difficulté qui tient à quelque chose qui
relève de la Concorde donc c'est un
amendement que nous défendrons dans
quelques minutes sur ce sujet
et comme nous sommes en discussion
commune
je dois vous demander de présenter aussi
l'amendement numéro 29 je crois que je
l'ai largement développé dans
l'amendement précédent
les rodéo urbains sont une plaie c'est
une
pratique qui
exaspèrent nos concitoyens qui
concourent un sentiment d'insécurité
réelle qui occasionne d'autres
difficultés pour autant il nous semble
que nous y avons travaillé assez
récemment c'est un phénomène qui a été
abordé par la loi du 3 août 2018 qui a
déjà créé une nouvelle infraction en
faisant de ces rodéo un délit
particulier
il nous semble que la difficulté la
difficulté actuelle elle réside
davantage dans la caractérisation de la
fraction qui défend qui dépend
d'éléments de preuve parfois complexes à
réunir et que la simple augmentation de
peine prévue pour ce délit ne suffira
pas à résoudre les difficultés de
terrain constatées dans de trop nombreux
quartiers de ce pays donc évidemment il
ne s'agit pas pour nous de dire on
laisse faire tout va bien il n'y a
aucune
aucune candeur aucun angélisme dans
notre position en revanche le souci de
l'efficacité et il nous semble que c'est
amendement qui visait très large à
l'époque un moment 99 n'atteint pas
complètement ses objectifs
merci enfin l'amendement 227 présenté
par la Commission
monsieur rapporteur de Brest c'est un
amendement purement de correction d'une
erreur matérielle qui ne pose pas de
difficulté à mon sens
et votre ami sur les amendements
j'ai écouté mes chers collègues
j'écoutais avec intérêt
et j'étais interpellé parce qu'a dit ma
collègue a mis Marie Mercier tout à
l'heure
sujet de philosophie pour papel un
parlementaire doit-il faire du droit ou
de la politique
tous les jours nous sommes interpellés
par cette question il doit faire les
deux bien sûr et comme l'a dit excellent
notre président et mon collègue
rapporteur lui RV avec de la rigueur et
de la méthode
je dis à mes collègues que cet
amendement que j'ai présenté
ne l'a pas été en amendement extérieur
après que la Commission soit réunie mais
ce que je vais peut-être être un tout
petit peu fastidieux mais je vous relis
ce qu'il y a dans le rapport de la
commission des lois
c'est à dire pourquoi j'ai été amené
avec mon collègue Loïc Hervé à vous
présenter cet amendement
tandis que nous refusions bien sûr des
amendements venant des groupes de
l'opposition mais aussi donnez-nous en
acte des amendements venant de la
majorité
je connais très bien les sujets
relatifs puisqu'on a fait la sécurité
globale avec mon ami Loic Hervé relatif
aux problèmes de la sécurité dans les
transports et sur le fond notre collecta
barreaux a raison mais tel que le
président a défini le périmètre en
essayant d'être le plus proche possible
évidemment du texte du ministre violence
commise sur la voie publique je ne
pouvais pas prendre les amendements de
Monsieur tabaron
monsieur retaillot a présenté un
amendement où nous avons donné un avis
défavorable et j'expliquais le président
retaillau qui l'a d'ailleurs très bien
compris pourquoi nous ne pouvions pas le
prendre parce qu'il n'était pas dans le
périmètre nous sommes chers collègues
nous en acte avec cet amendement que
j'ai présenté au nom de la Commission en
plein accord avec Loïc Hervé
dans le périmètre qui a été édicté pour
l'article 45 qui n'est pas fait pour
faire plaisir à tel ou tel mais pour que
nous soyons le plus rigoureux possible
et évitions évidemment des risques d'un
constitutionnalité sur lesquelles nous
sommes jamais à l'abri j'ai donc écrit
nous avons écrit les auditions conduites
par les rapporteurs ont montré l'urgence
et l'importance d'améliorer la réponse
pénale sur trois enjeux essentiels les
violences faites aux élus madame
Delattre s'est exprimée et à la
parfaitement raison
et j'aurais aimé pouvoir prendre son
amendement et je voterai des deux mains
lorsqu'ils viennent en discussion la PPL
qu'elle a faite avec des travaux
remarquables et sur lesquels évidemment
j'ai été 20 ans premier vice-président
de l'Association des mers du Nord
évidemment que nous sommes complètement
en phase avec tous ces sujets et les
premières choses que nous ont dites les
associations d'élus locaux c'est les
violences faites aux élus sur lequel je
pense il y a un large consensus et je
vous en remercie dans cette assemblée
nous sommes d'abord les représentants
des élus locaux plus 57% depuis un an
nous a dit le ministre on fait tous
notre travail je le sais avec
compétences et rigueur quelle que soit
les bancs on rencontre tous toutes les
semaines des élus c'est la première
chose qu'il nous disent en ce moment la
deuxième chose c'est l'énergie mais
c'est un autre sujet dont on a débattu
hier bon
ensuite
j'ai mis les refus d'obtempérer les
rodéo urbains parce qu'évidemment quand
nous rencontrons et que nous
auditionnons les la conférence des
procureurs quand nous auditionnons
les le barreau etc il y a un sujet qui
remonte en premier dont on a des battues
c'est la police judiciaire c'est clair
on l'a pas esquivé ce sujet là bon mais
il y a un autre sujet qui remonte chez
les policiers c'est les refus
d'obtempérer
et je vous interpelle là-dessus moi
c'est pas un secret mon père était
commissaire de police
et donc j'ai auditionné bien sûr toutes
les institutions mais dans mon bon
département du Nord j'ai eu des tas de
personnes que je connais qui m'ont dit
est-ce que vous pouvez nous recevoir
j'ai dit oui à titre informel je vais
pas mettre le rôle des rapporteurs c'est
d'auditionner d'abord les institutions
mais j'ai voulu me faire une idée
j'ai écouté d'ailleurs j'ai pas j'ai pas
amené mes opinions j'ai écouté ce qu'on
me disait ce qui vient en premier chez
les policiers que j'ai rencontrés c'est
les refus d'obtempérer
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
le ministre
et je suis très content d'avoir fait le
débat sur l'article 1 parce qu'on aurait
pu effectivement dire écouter désolé
c'est un rapport d'orientation il n'y a
pas de disposition législatives
perdons pas de temps mes chers collègues
on n'a pas perdu notre temps
et je remercie à nouveau le ministre du
temps qu'il a pris pour répondre
de temps en temps on se plaque les
ministres répondent parfois sous tous
les gouvernements parfois rapidement il
a pris beaucoup de temps beaucoup de
pédagogie pour vous expliquer ce qui
veut faire et pourquoi ils veulent faire
et moi qui est appartenu comme Madame
Rossignol d'ailleurs un gouvernement je
peux vous dire que de temps en temps le
ministre prend la plume lui-même il
écoute son cabinet mais quand il veut
imprimer une grande réforme à son
ministère parce qu'il est animé par ses
convictions on peut faire tous les
proches qu'on veut à Monsieur Darmanin
mais chacun a bien compris à travers
tout ce qui nous a dit qu'il était animé
par une forte conviction sur la les
réformes les réformes qui nous
présentent
il a répondu avec pédagogie et moi j'ai
été interpellé par ce chiffre parce que
Monsieur Durand vous savez très bien que
j'ai beaucoup d'estime et de respect
pour vous RSI frottement on a fait
ensemble une mission on a eu aucune
difficulté parce qu'on a posé les
problèmes et qu'on l'a fait on l'a pas
fait de manière partisane mais dans le
souci du traitement de l'image que
d'ailleurs sur lequel a beaucoup
travaillé Loïc Hervé on a un rapport
commun il y a pas eu la moindre
difficulté d'arbitrage d'accord mais
vous nous avez fait un amendement hier
soir sur le texte avant-hier soir sur le
texte du ministre
ou ce qui est légitime vous vous posiez
la question est-ce que c'est en
alourdissant les peines que vous allez
mieux lutter contre les refus
d'obtempérer et je respecte l'opinion je
veux dire ce c'est je n'ai pas de je
comprends dans la logique de vos
arguments la cohérence de votre opinion
et par définition je la respecte
et je vous cache pas que je me suis
aussi posé cette question or monsieur
durat il vous a donné les chiffres
suivants excusez-moi monsieur le
ministre d'aller rechercher vos chiffres
mais
les le nombre de refus d'obtempérer a
augmenté finalement de 27%. j'avais dit
17 c'est 27 et pourquoi j'ai présenté
parce que le ministre nous a fait une
réunion de travail à la place bobo de
toute la commission des lois et que j'ai
été très interpellé par ce chiffre qui
nous a donné mais les tirs vous avez dit
en fait depuis qu'on autorise les tirs
de manière plus bon finalement ça
s'aggrave quoi
2017 sans deux tirs de la police
nationale 52 de la gendarmerie 254 2021
157 tirs de la police nationale 44 la
gendarmerie 200 autrement dit les refus
d'obtempérer augmentent fortement
et le nombre de tirs avec toutes les
conséquences ça suppose et le drame que
c'est parfois pour des victimes qui sont
à côté d'un conducteur fou mais aussi le
drame que c'est permettez-moi de le dire
pour les policiers
parce qu'il faut pas croire qu'un
policier à 3h du matin il tire comme un
cow-boy que pour non pas du tout c'est
un drame d'utiliser son arme à drame bon
et bien ça montre bien
que
le nombre de tirs a diminué
parce que chacun bien conscience de la
gravité des choses mais que les refus
d’obtempérer ne cesse d'augmenter
et Monsieur le récepteur monsieur le
rapporteur c'est important je défends je
défends trois réponses en même temps
pouvez-vous vous approcher du moment où
vous serez la position de la Commission
quand j'étais conseiller régional
c'était monsieur Morrois Président
Monsieur diligent
et Monsieur non monsieur Joseph et
diligent disait je m'appelle diligent
donc je vais vite et vous vous appelez
Monsieur Joseph donc vous êtes juste
donc merci de votre compréhension je
m'approche de ma conclusion refus
d'obtempérer nous pensons que alourdir
les peines aura un aspect préventif
monsieur benaroche je vous réponds au
passage sur les réductions de peine
allez retrouver le PV du Sénat sur la
loi sécurité globale vous verrez la
manière
dont j'ai refusé des amendements qu'elle
est trop loin sur les réductions de
peine en prenant une partie de votre
argumentation mais sur ce sujet là je le
fais et je termine sur les rôdées
urbains pour dire que les
urbains je propose pas qu'on sanctionne
plus gravement tous les rôles je propose
quand ils mettent en danger la vie
d'autrui et on est bien sur les violents
sur la voie urbaine pour toutes ces
raisons monsieur le Président je vais
rejeter tous les amendements sauf celui
de coordination rédactionnelle et donc
j'invite mes collègues à voter pour
qu'ils puissent répondre aux
préoccupations des uns et des autres
monsieur le ministre la vie du
gouvernement
merci monsieur le Président de quoi
parle-t-on dans cet article additionnel
souhaité par la commission des lois mais
qui n'était pas dans le texte initial du
gouvernement ce qui d'ailleurs me pousse
à dire que sur le fond on peut partager
un certain nombre de constat évoqué par
Monsieur les rapporteurs sur la forme
nous ne posons une question qui est
quand même celui du fait que ce soit
peut-être un cavalier législatif mais je
comprends bien que la Commission
puisqu'elle l'accident 45 en discute je
donnerai un avis de sagesse pour
l'ensemble des amendements puisque on a
eu l'occasion d'en parler avec les
rapporteurs je partage totalement les
constats que une grande partie du Sénat
fait d'abord sur les élus il est vrai
que ces augmentations sont très
importantes à 35 % d'augmentation des
atteintes contre les élus 1720 fait ont
été constatés par le renseignement
territorial
898 fait au visé des élus locaux puisque
évidemment lorsqu'on dit des personnes
des présidentielles autorité celui qu'il
n'y a pas que des élus locaux c'était
une augmentation de 50 2% pardon 52% de
ces faits soit 78% d'augmentation par
rapport à 2020 donc voilà je pense quand
même de la traite tout à fait raison et
d'après les remontées de l'ensemble des
sommes de veille mis à l'intérieur 1037
procédures établies impliquant un élu
comme victime ont été constatés dans 157
pour violences physiques et 808 pour
menaces ou outrage donc évidemment c'est
un problème très important peut être
d'accord avec la disposition de la
commission des lois je veux redire pour
les remises de peine que nous avons
supprimées de manière automatique mais
que nous n'avez pas supprimer de manière
individuelle s'agissant dans le texte
porté par le garde des sceaux que si
Arbis de peine il y a effort de la part
de la personne qui a été condamnée à
remise de PET automatique c'était sans
effort donc je pense que ce débat a été
en partie tranchée de manière générale
après le problème particulier qui évoqué
monsieur le rapporteur je veux dire
effectivement que ça devrait a suivi je
crois la position qui était celle
conforme de notre droit pour les remises
de peine sur les rodéo qu'il ne faut pas
confondre avec les refuses tempérés de
quoi parle-t-on depuis le 1er janvier
2022 nous avons constaté 3808
infractions de rodéo relevés contre 2737
en 2021 sur la même période évidemment
il s'agit des rodéo relevés soit par les
services de police nationale municipal
gendarmerie soit par les caméras de
vidéoprojection il ne présente pas
constater l'ensemble des rodéo qui ne
sont pas toujours fait sous une caméra
de protection ou sous un policier ou
Jésus impossible d'un gendarme depuis le
15 mai vous aurez constaté à la suite de
mes interventions notamment médiatiques
l'intensification des mobilisations des
services de l'État pour lutter contre
ces fléaux vous l'avez tous dit qui
perturbent grandement la vie nos
concitoyens
75000 opérations ont été mis en place
vers une augmentation de 50% des
contrôles 3250 véhicules saisis sans le
doigt à la loi que la majorité
parlementaire de l'Assemblée nationale a
fait voter que vous avez bien voulu
accompagner dans les messieurs les
sénateurs
5350 interpellations réalisées dans ce
cadre on voit bien de quoi nous parlons
un 3800 infractions constatées en 2021
en 2022 pardon si on constate les
chiffres de cette année il y a eu
quasiment des interprétations sur tous
les héros des hauts constatés lorsque
les services de police et gendarmerie
était sur place la question qui se pose
et finalement c'est la question que pose
le rapporteur dans son amendement qui
crée cet article c'est quels sont les
suites judiciaires ce je crois que ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que désormais
les moyens de la police gendarmerie sont
assez forts pour intervenir pour ses
Rodeo la question c'est quelle
condamnation et qu'elle poursuites
pénale lorsqu'on fait ses
interpellations nombreuses alors nous
avons les chiffres de l'année 2021 parmi
les 1000 325 mis en cause dans les
affaires de rodéo qui ont été orientés
ainsi par les différents parquets 248 on
bénéficié d'un classement sans suite
pour infraction non poursuivable 22 la
46 pour une opportunité des poursuites
234 ont une mesure alternative aux
poursuites
une personne une composition pénale et
760 quand même qu'on fait l'objet de
poursuites qui sont encore en cours
devant les tribunaux et donc allant vers
une peine de prison ferme en tout cas
possible
constatons qu'il n'y a donc que 22 15 68
pour une opportunité des poursuites
c'est à dire que je crois que les
parquets ont compris quels étaient
l'intention de législateur et décide de
poursuivre un maximum de choses si je
prends toute l'année 2021 et donc pour
la part aux années précédentes 1159
personnes ont été condamnées pour une
infraction de rodéo ce qu'il faudrait
désormais voir c'est quels sont les
quantums de peine pour appliquer la
réflexion de monsieur le rapporteur et
donc quelles sont les résultats des
juges du siège mais en tout cas je
voulais apporter à votre assemblée ces
chiffres également pour ceux qui nous
regardent pour les refus d'obtempérer
qui ne sont pas pareils que les hauts de
haut mais un rodéo peut se transformer
malheureusement en fait de tempérer donc
évidemment tout ça y est nous comprenons
la philosophie de l'amendement du
rapporteur 28000 faits de refus de
tempérer en 2021 un refus de tempérer
désormais tous les 20 minutes en zone
police comme en zone gendarmerie en
augmentation constante je pense que ça a
été dit par Monsieur de rapporteur
j'aurais d'ailleurs souligné que parmi
les refuses tempérés il y a il y a deux
types de refuses tempérés il y a celui
qui met pas en danger la vie d'autrui et
à celui qui meurt en danger la vie
d'autrui pour ceux qui sont mis en
danger la vie d'autrui c'est plus 41% de
refus de tempérer dans des circonstances
exposants directement autrui à un risque
de mort ou d'infirmité et notamment
évidemment les services de police de
gendarmerie ou les agents de sécurité
civile ou même les agents des autoroutes
par exemple que l'on voit et qui parfois
demande à ralentir et qui connaissent
malheureusement des conduites très
dangereuses de la part de criminels de
la route près de 20 000 faits sur les 9
premiers mois ont déjà été constatés en
2022 donc ça va pas s'arranger et que
c'est statistiques vont continuer à
augmenter je voudrais ici souligner
qu'il y a eu plus de 9000 policiers
gendarmes blessés en mission depuis
trois ans soit les refuges d'obtempérer
9000 mesdames messieurs c'est la
première cause de blessures dans la
police et d'un jardin compris national
donc pour toutes ces raisons je veux
dire à monsieur le rapporteur que nous
comprenons et que nous approuvons
l'article 7 bis nos option peut-être la
difficulté de forme mais je fais
confiance évidemment à votre commission
des Lois nous serons prêts à améliorer
peut-être le dispositif si le permet à
la nationale et s'il était voté par
exemple monsieur le rapporteur j'ai
constaté dans les services de police cet
été et pour voir quel était
l'amélioration que nous voulions
apporter à la loi qui avait été adopté
notamment au premier en première lecture
par l'Assemblée nationale il y a
notamment des difficultés de saisie des
véhicules lorsque ces motos c'est quoi
de ces voitures sont officiellement
prêtées puis déclarer voler c'est à dire
que je prends la voiture de mon camarade
je fais le tour en étant extrêmement
dangereux je me fais interpeller par les
services de police et le camarade le
sait puisque un petit texto est échangé
et je déclare au service de police que
ce camarade me l'a volé évitant ainsi la
saisie du véhicule alors que désormais
nous saisissons systématiquement ces
véhicules donc il faut face attention à
ces petits détournements de la procédure
sans doute est-ce le genre de
d'amendement que le gouvernement
pourrait porter aussi l'Assemblée
nationale serait ouvert mais pour tout
vous dire nous ont donc un avis de
sagesse sur l'ensemble des arguments des
amendements pardon avec ces arguments et
peut-être un avis favorable à un moment
de coordination du rapporteur évidemment
qui porte pas préjudice
monsieur Durin redemande paroles pour
une explication de vote
merci monsieur le Président
bon j'ai largement exposé ce qui nous
avait déterminé
à déposer ses amendements de suppression
sur rodéo urbain et refus d'obtempérer
sur les rodéo urbains nous ont
questionnons l'efficacité sur les
refuses tempérés nous ne partageons pas
la réflexion initiale et les constats
notre groupe va prendre ses
responsabilités nous sommes extrêmement
attachés
à la défense de l'exercice du mandat
d'élus mise en cause par des agressions
verbales des agressions physiques il y a
des exemples dans tout de départements
et dans le département de Saône-et-Loire
que je représente ici avec d'autres
sénateurs et sénatrices récemment encore
un maire a abandonné son mandat pour
avoir été agressé par un de ses
concitoyens
donc nous voterons cet article et nous
allons continuer le combat sur les
refuses de tempérer notamment au moyen
de l'amendement 119 déposés en articles
additionnels après l'article 7 bis pour
aller au bout des arguments que nous
souhaitons défendre tout en de
partageant pas les prémices de la
réflexion du rapporteur sur ces trois
objets qui nous sommes de nature
différente et qui nous amène à
finalement pencher du côté il vous
favorable alors que sur deux des aspects
nous sommes plutôt opposés
[Musique]
monsieur benaroche pour explication de
vote sur l'un des amendements
d'une manière plus précise en fait sur
les refus d'obtempérer parce que sur le
reste tout a été dit je pense par mes
collègues et je partage et l'opinion
concernant les élus et l'opinion
concernant Jérôme Durand sur les rodéo
ce qui me gêne et ce qui me dérange en
fait dans ce qui a été rajouté sur les
refus d'obtempérer
je pense que la démonstration des
éléments qui nous ont été donnés par
Monsieur le minis chiffré sur un constat
sur lequel il faut effectivement
s'interroger de la même façon et je vous
en remercie d'ailleurs monsieur le
ministre de la même façon d'ailleurs
qu'il faut s'interroger aussi sur on va
dire les c'est pas des bavures c'est
plus que ça sur les drames qui arrivent
aujourd'hui
drame que vivent en premier lieu les
forces de l'ordre et bien entendu que
vivent les personnes qui ont sur les
victimes lors de lors de ces refuses en
tempéré alors il semblerait et c'est ça
qui lui choque la solution qui nous est
proposée c'est une solution qui dit
finalement si on veut régler ça il faut
augmenter les peines
on sait très bien
permet de dire d'ailleurs monsieur le
rapporteur que les auditions qui ont pu
être menées et d'autres auditions qu'on
pourrait mener d'ailleurs dans le cadre
lois notre bien qu'en fait c'est pas
l'augmentation de peine sur ce sujet qui
va résoudre le problème aujourd'hui des
refus d'obtempérer je rappelle aussi
d'ailleurs que
nonobstant les peines dans beaucoup
d'autres pays
les refus d'obtempérer même s'ils sont
importants ne débouchent pas sur
le nombre de de drames que nous avons
vécu en France et que nous vivons
aujourd'hui ça montre quoi me
semble-t-il dans une certaine cohérence
de réflexion ça montre que ce n'est pas
la peine qui fait le problème ce qui
fait le problème c'est plusieurs choses
c'est la formation des policiers c'est
la façon d'utiliser les armes c'est la
façon de faire ces contrôles qui ensuite
aboutissent sur ces refus d'obtempérer
surtout cela nous sommes d'accord pour
collaborer faire une mission réfléchir
auditionner mais il nous paraît
prématuré pour contrat de vos termes
monsieur le rapporteur sur d'autres
sujets aujourd'hui d'introduire une
seule solution comme si c'était la
solution unique qui risque d'occulter ce
problème mais pas pour longtemps parce
que ça continuera même pas d'augmenter
d'être un problème qui se auquel nous
nous heurterons je vais mettre voix les
quatre amendements suivants qui sont
évidemment différents donc ce sont bien
quatre votes je mets d'abord aux voiles
amendement 64 présenté par monsieur
benaroche qui est favorable
quels sont ceux qui sont contre
nous passons au deuxième amendement
numéro 28 présenté par Monsieur Durin
quels sont ceux qui sont pour
quelles sont ceux qui sont contre
et ne pas il n'est pas adoptée
amendement 29 est-ce que c'est le même
vote
même vote elle adopter et enfin
l'amendement 227
de la commission qui a obtenu un avis
peut-être favorable si je me rappelle
bien du gouvernement
bien quels sont ceux qui sont pour
contre
[Musique]